ante la mirada de los primeros
visitantes el cartel oficial del
festival se despliega sobre la famosa
alfombra roja de katman una fotografía
de la Estrella de cine tomada En 1968
ocupa este año un lugar de honor
precioso es muy bonito un cartel muy
bonito
es un homenaje a kathry han hecho una
buena elección creando estos carteles
para el lugar principal
para el cine francés Es muy importante
creo que para muchos franceses ella
representa realmente el cine que conocen
la hija de hará más troyani será la
presentadora tanto de la ceremonia de
apertura el martes por la noche como de
la clausura el 27 de mayo 21 películas
optan a suceder a la ganadora de la
palma de oro del año pasado triángulo de
la tristeza cuyo director Rubén preside
este año el Jurado varios directores
aspiran a su segunda palma de oro como
un ánimo de ti
por su parte el veterano cineasta
británico de 86 años aspira a completar
una tripleta sin precedentes el festival
a menudo criticado por marginar a las
directoras también ha seleccionado un
récord de siete películas dirigidas por
mujeres para la competición principal
entre ellas
de la directora francesa mayween de
montada por agredir a un periodista de
investigación la edición de este año se
celebrará en un clima de máxima
seguridad mientras continúan las
protestas por la reforma de las
pensiones en todo el país